I'm standing here with the grey magic
Johnson so cool to see you sir yeah we
got straight right away how tall are you
6 9 you were 6 9 ok I am 6 4 and then
with the harem butts about 7 feet 2
inches tall now be honest with me my
build would it be a problem in the NBA
yes it would
why did you be so honest you know why
didn't you just say something polite
like oh you'd be great
why did you have to do that well I gotta
tell you the truth now what's the
problem the problem is you just don't
have the muscles you don't have them the
mass either the oh you don't have it oh
I took pretty good trash I see that you
like labor labor used to talk about
trash I almost look a little like Larry
Bird the only thing missing is I need a
tiny little what do you have was his
mustache made of three blond hairs
that's now and they just didn't leave
and put it all together is that what
they do Larry I grew up in Boston I grew
up during that era young man that's when
I'm in high school that's when I'm in
college watching you guys play and I was
always rooting for bird because now you
gonna tell me no I rooted for him
conceives the palest sickest man and he
was playing in the NBA remember the hot
pans we used to win oh my god you guys
back your shorts this is what it used to
be like when you were this is what it
meant to be in the NBA
this is me and 1980 this is me playing
in the NBA 1982 that's the short my
dream has long been to play a game of
horse with Magic Johnson you start this
game of horse
[Applause]
I got an H right there right there right
there okay I'm moving hor now that's
right I propose we change this from the
game of course to horse-drawn carriage
in the 19th century there we go am i
okay this is okay [ __ ]
oh come on I'm just lucky I don't know
what it is I'm just lucky man
this is a standard pool skimmer okay
what you gotta do is you gotta you got
to move to the basket right right right
and then you got to get it in the basket
Oh Oh with the pool skimmer just like
that it's not as easy as it looks now I
gotta also run like new right yeah run
like me just bring back any memories
this bring back any memories of magic
you're in its Boston Garden its Boston
Garden coming for me okay here we go I
got it all right here we go
[Music]
all right I got the master man this is
the first time I'm wearing a white bass
here this is a strange nightmare I'm
having me do something
I got Labor's face on as a black man
what are you gonna do I'm gonna come
across the middle of the lane and then
imma shoot the hook this is the famous
jr. jr. sky
[Applause]
okay well this is a shocking shocking
upset I mean the beach I don't know you
I am starving I lost so we don't get
lunch whatever you want let's just get
some jack-in-the-box that'll be real oh
yeah all right I'm gonna get it from
getting from door dad oh come here
yeah this is pretty simple actually Oh
oh great fantastic thank you thank you
very much yeah hey I don't know what you
got going on right now but we rented
this court for an hour so and we got a
lot of time left so feel free to write
difficult into him so now he got a feed
yeah okay have fun
[Applause]
thanks to Magic Johnson
joy to spend time with that man what a
dream that was fantastic
you